il faudra être en cours et les cherry on
en a quelques uns en ligne pour jouer
avec nous alors oui bonjour monsieur
bonjour oui allô oui bonjour qu'est
comment vous appelez jarrier ça c'est
xavier bonjour janvier tarek fatah
carrick man 10 à vieille chapelle
n'attendent que sony
est en délire comme un salut à mon papa
est pas tombé sur une seule paire normal
nous serions pas basé sur un gars normal
xavier tu nous a beaucoup manqué vous
vous manquer mais je n'ai pas choisi mon
prénom
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les appeler ou que ça fier alsace à
strasbourg
j'habite est exactement l
âme des piles âge a beaucoup aidés
mutuellement on vous laissez moi parler
[Applaudissements]
sa pièce que vous les joies des normes
ta gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
pourquoi s'énerver comme ça tu t'es fait
larguer par tamas ou quoi je suis gay
alors comment il s'appelle d'audience et
match
et surtout francis a peut être pas à
quelle
base quelles c'est plutôt mon amoureux
du moment sega d'allemand
[Applaudissements]
m
et
après on se rend compte que évidemment
c'est vous déjà fait avoir dans une
émission hockey jamie info michel cymes
et
c'était sûr de pépé bien sûr l'argument
info michel cymes et ont alors
copieusement insulté ouais et vous êtes
monté dans les tours également répondu
avec mon peu de répartie j'étais ce qui
l'est plus
bon bah oui syrine qui m'avait appelé se
faisait passer pour patrick ben oui
c'est vrai vous avez cru voyez dans un
restaurant j'ai attendu non vous n'êtes
pas là mais non magistrats oui sur ma
vie chalet attendu sur ma djellaba
et il m'a envoyé des sms disait sharim
et où je commence à pas je suis juste
une question et c'était que par sms qui
vous appelez d'abord au téléphone après
on était chez moi cyril sait faire
patrice munsch aussi permis j' ai cru et
chari vais m'en voyez ça m est remonté
cyril m'appelle et me dit mais qu'est ce
tu fait chiper baja temps
en fait ils m'ont fait vibrer des sushis
je mangeais tout seul et tous attendent
et et puis en fait j'ai vu cyril il
s'était il est en train de se prendre
une part de rire au restaurant al
ousboue
me regarder l'été avec notre ami
stéphane hasbanian je cite à ce soir est
en fait il se foutait
[Applaudissements]
un tabou absolu à beine-nauroy non bien
sûr et vous n'avez jamais déjeuné avec
patrick bruel
patrick bruel quand même et bah il m'a
jamais répondu mais
pour une fan est l'adresse de patrie
brève hausse et qu'il m'a donné cyril
non il m'a envoyé dans un resto votre
élève de patrick houel alors j'écris sur
un seul
accord valérie et les oubliez pas les
choses
[Rires]